como
30 días después no es el escenario
idílico que esperaban los votantes y el
propio gabriel boric cuando se posesionó
como presidente de chile el mandatario
más joven de la historia del país del
cono sur cumple un mes al frente del
palacio de la moneda y confiesa que el
aterrizaje fue turbulento la
controversia generada en el ministerio
de interior cuando la ministra a izq ya
sitges culpó al ex presidente piñera por
la expulsión irregular de emigrantes las
tensiones con los mapuches como parte de
un enquistado conflicto entre el estado
los indígenas y las empresas agrícolas y
forestales y los continuos ataques de la
oposición han marcado las primeras
semanas de su mandato que según expertos
no será fácil por la crisis de
legitimidad que atraviesa el país a
todas las escalas esa desconfianza se
rebasa la élite acá tenemos una crisis
de legitimidad de las élites elite de la
iglesia de la política del empresariado
y por lo tanto frente a esa crisis de
desconfianza y por dicho cualquiera que
llegue al poder siempre van a estar en
tela de juicio por parte de la
ciudadanía a una inflación disparada se
sumaron en los últimos días las
protestas contra la nueva constitución
que se votará el próximo 4 de septiembre
por otro lado las marchas de cada
viernes en los aledaños de la
rebautizada plaza dignidad kilómetro
cero del estallido social continúan pese
a las promesas del mandatario
no solamente desde el 18 de octubre sino
que hace muchos años atrás
hemos estado organizando en la calle
no hay solución posible con esta
bombilla ferré defensor de la nueva
carta magna para garantizar un cambio
estructural boric tiene que garantizar
su aprobación para legitimar su
liderazgo tanto a escala nacional como
en la región